c'est l'heure de la revue de presse
internationale bourgeois hélène bonjour
damien est à la une de cette presse
internationale ce matin il élabore la
victoire hier de rafael nadal à roland
garros face au au norvégien casper run
le 14e titre décroché par l'espagnol sur
la terre battue parisienne 17 ans après
sa première coupe des mousquetaires il y
a eu damien deux papes l'espagne a
compté deux rois trois présidents 104
milices traverser une pandémie et le
royaume uni est sorti de lieux mais il
ya une chose qui ne change pas c'est
toujours rafa qui gagne grande émotion
l'entente ce matin du côté du quotidien
sportif marca émerveillé par la
domination implacable dans rafael nadal
sur roland garros nadal l'unique titre
simplement le quotidien abc à propos de
ce champion interminable infinie dont
aucun adversaire ne semble pouvoir venir
à bout quatorze victoires vous l'avait
dit et le mundo s'en frottent encore les
yeux et salue la performance du joueur
de 36 ans parvenu à décrocher son 22e
sacre en grand chelem malgré une douleur
intense au pied gauche hommage aussi
enfin de l'équipe qui fait entrer
l'espagnol dans l'éternité l'éternité
sur terre battue quelle que soit la
suite qu'il donnera à sa carrière rafael
nadal s'installe plus que jamais au
sommet de son sport s'incline bons
joueurs le quotidien sportif français
autre sujet qu'on retrouve dans les
journaux on en parlait d'ailleurs dans
notre journal à nous cette attaque hier
au nigeria où des hommes armés ont fait
irruption dans une église d'euros dans
le sud ouest du pays lors d'une
célébration de la pentecôte nous face à
ce nouveau massacre qui aura fait une
cinquantaine de victimes dont des
enfants de punch exprime son indignation
et sa colère vis-à-vis du gouvernement
certains nigérians s'attendait à ce que
le président boyrie un ancien général à
la retraite soit le mieux placé pour
résoudre le problème persistant des
attaques des différentes milices dans le
pays malheureusement cela n'a pas été le
cas et ses attaques jusqu'à leurs
limites et au nord-est du pays se sont
étendues à presque toutes les régions le
pays quotidien burkinabè s'alarme de
voir le terrorisme semblait reprendre du
poil de la bête au niger malgré la mort
l'année dernière d'aboubakar shekau le
leader de la secte islamiste boko haram
si l'on ne connaît pas pour le moment
l'identité des auteurs de ce massacre
qui pourrait aussi bien être l'oeuvre de
lits swap la branche ouest africaine du
groupe etat islamique le pays dénonce
une barbarie qu'aucune religion ne
saurait cautionner et l'échec de la
politique sécuritaire mis en place
depuis une dizaine d'années y compris
donc pas le président houari et qui
avait promis lors de son arrivée au
pouvoir en 2015 d'en finir je le cite
avec l'hydre terroriste sous 60 jours la
presse burkinabè qui exprime aussi ce
matin sa déception face à la décision de
la cedeao la communauté des états
d'afrique de l'ouest de de reporter le 3
juillet prochain annonce de sanctions
contre les putschistes du mali mais
aussi du burkina faso et de guinée mais
les dirigeants ouest africains réunis
samedi au ghana n'ont pas réussi à se
mettre d'accord
au grand dam de l'observateur paalga si
même mohamadou buhari qui n'est pas
réputé pour être un élève assidu de la
cedeao étaient là c'est que ce sommet
extraordinaire devait déboucher sur
quelque chose d'extraordinaire et
pourtant la présence de baba go slow
n'aura pas fait bouger les lignes et il
n'en fallait pas plus pour que certains
parlent d'un sommet pour rien commente
le journal cedeao sur le mali la guinée
le burkina rien à voir repasser le 3
juillet ironise enfin pour sa part le
site d'info burkinabè wakat c'est un mot
à présent de de la mise en garde
adressée par le liban à israël accusé
d'empiéter sur une zone maritime
disputée entre les deux pays d'après lui
rien le jour cette montée au créneau
libanaise intervient après l'arrivée
hier d'une unité flottante de production
et de stockage pour commencer à
exploiter le champ gazier de cas riche
pour le compte de l'état hébreu qui
assure qu'il se trouve dans sa zone
économique exclusive et non dans la zone
maritime disputée avec le liban le
figaro évoque un litige qui remonte à
2011 et bloqués depuis par l'amateurisme
je cite de beyrouth capitale d'un pays
où les intérêts personnels et les
influences étrangères liées des intérêts
géopolitiques prime sur l'intérêt
national un affrontement où se dessinent
deux camps celui du hezbollah et de ses
amis est celui des alliés des etats-unis
au sens large avec pour conséquence de
laisser le liban je cite totalement
absent de la reconfiguration stratégique
en cours dans la méditerranée
consécutive à la guerre en ukraine et
pour finir on part au royaume uni où la
fête finie ça hier les festivités du
jubilé qui s'est déroulé les 70 ans de
règne de la de la reine elizabeth ont
pris fin hier dimanche et l'apparition
surprise de la souveraine au balcon et
fière de buckingham palace pour clôturer
sa célébration fait la une ce matin
damien de toute la presse outre manche
touché par les mots d'elisabeth 2 qui
s'est dit ému par l'élan d'amour de ses
compatriotes mon coeur est avec vous
tous a déclaré la souveraine déclaré
surprise donc par les quotidiens
britanniques la reine elizabeth 2 est
aussi apparu à l'occasion de ce jubilé
dans un message vidéo humoristique avec
l'ours paddington le prenant le thé avec
ce héros de la littérature pour enfants
britanniques dans le dessein de
motorland pour the times la souveraine
on le voit a été remplacé par boris
johnson dans la tourmente depuis le
parti guette le premier ministre serait
désormais à deux doigts de la motion de
censure le jeu de mots est assez
intraduisible damian mais pour résumer
l'ours paddington voyant beaux jo c'est
coulante à table se dit que c'est
peut-être à cause de l'alcool à cause
des soirées très arrosées à downing
street vous l'avez dit le lendemain de
fête a dormi street risque de tourner à
la gueule de bois au lendemain de fête
difficile parfois merci beaucoup elle a
une phrase